[Music]
so I just got me out snore and I'm
pretty excited because this was the last
pair of air pods that they have in at
the store they started shipping a few
days ago but today was the day that they
were in the store remember 19 2016 9
made a video on YouTube saying I got my
air pause about 3 days ago
February 18th 2017 I made a video
talking about air pod straps straps that
you put on your air pods so you won't
lose them I'm sure many of you have been
waiting patiently for this video
when will I just steam lose her ear pods
and guess what I made it sixty-four days
the irony is I just made a few days ago
that video talking about how I haven't
lost them and I was so excited if the
air pods strap which I never even
actually ended up using the strap
there's no good story about how I lost
them I didn't just lose the air pods
that go into my ear I lost the entire
case my sister it was like where did you
lose them and I said well if I knew
where I lost them they wouldn't be lost
they would be found but they're not
they're not found they're lost
here's the bad news I went to reorder
myself a pair of ear pods and they said
that it would take at least six weeks to
shift so apparently the air pods are
still kind of difficult to get
I'm fake crying I wasn't even I wasn't
even like a good fake cried and that was
just dramatic I'm sure I'm gonna hear it
all in the comments the air pods are
stupid this is what Apple once they want
you to lose them but the fact that I
actually have kept them that long is
kind of incredible and I didn't we I
don't even know a good story about it
I'm pretty sure I just left them in the
hotel room I just got back from vacation
vacation vlogs coming up tomorrow I just
thought that I would address what
happened because I talked about it on
Twitter and I didn't really go to detail
and everyone wanted to hear the story of
how I lost the air pods
there's no good story at all app there's
absolutely no good story but this jiff
is probably one of my most favorite
things that I've ever seen on the trip
[Music]
or the beach I don't know if I knew they
would not be lost and people who end up
seeing air pods out and about they don't
know what they are they just assume that
it's dental floss so who's gonna be like
wow I think I'm gonna save the son of
floss for you because you probably are
gonna come back to the hotel or to the
pool to get it
you're not listen here Justine
[Applause]
my second pair of ear pods I'm not gonna
lie that hit that I just did on my head
it hurt a lot because I hit the bridge
of my nose I'm not happy about this it's
not like this is something that I'm
excited about it wasting money on and
because I couldn't wait six weeks I
travel a lot this is basically the only
thing that I use now for headphones and
I can't believe that I actually like
them so much that I already am not sure
how to live without them some of my
favorite comments on the previous video
that I made about the air pods drops why
don't you just keep the ones that came
with the iPhone the ones that have the
wires the ear buds not the air pots
because essentially you're just making
yourself new here but I know trust me
I've heard it all I know this is me
[Music]
it'll have a smell I should put like an
ape found sweet me think I wanna put
like this is not dental floss please
return to owner I'd appreciate it I
managed to get these in the airport on
eBay basically overnight shipping so I
haven't had to go a day without them are
you spoiled Justine are you split yes I
am but guess what
these are the things that I choose to
waste my money on it is my money to
waste I'm not proud of it
feel free to hate all you want in the
comments I know I know
I've heard it all before I've read it
all before nothing you can say will sway
my opinion of how I feel about the
things that I choose to do in my life
okay am I having a mental breakdown
perhaps I am do you want to talk about
it I'm clearly talking about it right
now another thing that I would like to
discuss is the fact that they removed me
find my iPods airpot find my ear pods
feature from the iOS beta this is
something that's need to be very
important I will please put it back put
it back I need to know where they are we
also make it so that I'm able to find
these on GPS like Find My iPhone I want
to know exactly where it is it all time
isn't on my body is it near my body is
it in my body I need to know where are
my air pods because I don't want to lose
them again I need to make myself a
little sticky note I've got a label
maker and I'm gonna get to label it well
thank you guys for watching I hope to
bring you a better joy-filled video
tomorrow filled with lots of joy lots of
joy and just know that at the time of
that video being filmed my ear pods were
still in my possession so I hope that
somebody finds them and they can give
them a new home and love them the way
that I did for two months
see you later it's been the only thing
that I've wanted to talk about I've
wanted to show what you wanted to post
on Instagram I've wanted to post it on
snapchat I've wanted to even post it on
Facebook so I flip it over and I see
94/95 and I'm like what that's
ridiculous
that snaps a little waste of money I
need it
the fact is this cup fits on my head
it's tearing